how much fun did you have doing runaways
um how much fun it was so cool it was
it's marvel it's you did three seasons
three seasons three seasons why only
three seasons um i think streaming-wise
i think it's i think financially
they that's the cutting point you have
to potentially renegotiate with um
everybody
after the third season they don't have
to but i think that it's sort of an
unspoken and you would have killed them
and renegotiated i i uh you would have
said i want so much money it's disney i
don't think anyone kills disney in uh in
negotiations you know
i think you're right i don't think
anybody kills anybody in negotiations
but what was that like i mean it was a
fun character to play really fun
character to play i learned a lot on the
visual effects side of stuff i thought
that was great um
because you always had the dinosaur the
dinosaur right and they had like
animatronics and you had a special
effects team and i mean they put money
behind it yeah they spent a fortune on
the show also it was a dream of mine to
shoot a paramount i remember when my mom
and dad were because you lived near
there yeah well i live yet 15 minutes
but i think i remember when i first
moved to la sitting outside
praying with my mom in the car of like
you know oh i'm going into an audition i
hope i work here one day and then
literally to have a key code you know to
have the pass but every morning you then
check in and you just drive in and you
say hi to the security guards and like
you see the paramount sign
and you're the first trailers
right there on paramount it's like wait
what is happening here like to remind
myself to pinch myself a lot i had to
remind myself to pinch myself a lot
because it was like wait i dreamed at
this moment you really prayed with your
mom in the car yeah like what do you
mean you closed your eyes yeah and what
did you say did you speak out loud or
did you feel a silent prayer i'm quite
an internal uh internal prayer yeah so
it was one of those things did you hold
hands
she just kind of closed your eyes you
closed your eyes and you just said what
you needed to say
she probably said something like you
know bless my son he's a good kid and he
doesn't mean bone in his body he doesn't
do any snort yeah and doesn't do
anything oh he's a good kid
let him work on this lot this is a dream
of his yeah whatever that is and then
i'm sure the praying continued once i
got out the car yeah i'm sure she was
praying from then to the end when i came
back right